are you sure yeah being a venture first
man to walk on the moon that'd be
something we've chosen a job so
difficult requiring so many
technological developments we're gonna
have to start from scratch
only after we mastered these tasks do we
consider trying to land on the moon
Neal if his flight is successful you'll
go down in history what kind of thoughts
do you have about that planning on the
flight being successful
and that is a big mother it'll go up
like a half kiloton a bomb if it blows
the vehicles not safe you need to fail
down here so we don't fail up there this
isn't just another trip Neil you're not
was going to work do you think you're
coming back there are risks but we have
every intention of coming back
somebody got a Swiss Army knife Swiss
Army knife gimme five four three
do you question whether the program is
worth the cost in money in unless you're
down here and they look up and you don't
think about it too much but space
exploration changes your perception and
it allows us to see things that we
should have seen a long time ago we have
serious problems we've got this under
control you're a bunch of boys you don't
have anything to control
[Music]